okay so a lot of reaction to my story
about patreon from yesterday as I
pointed out yesterday over the weekend
or a few days ago patreon which is a
platform we use to fundraise for the
show I changed their fee structure and
moved a little more of the fee that they
collect from the publisher the david
pakman show to the patron with the idea
being that the publisher the producer
would end up with ninety five percent of
every dollar pledged and they completely
bungled this announcement they admit
they've emailed me and said we made a
big mistake and how we did this it was
not good and we're gonna try to work it
out but unfortunately has been crushing
us because we've been losing patrons if
you go to patreon.com/scishow you'll
notice that the number of patrons which
normally goes up throughout the month
has actually been going down down down
throughout the month and we are still
losing patrons and it's a sad situation
in particular because a lot of the
people that are understandably upset
with patreon canceling their patreon
pledges are canceling them but then not
like coming over to our website and
signing up for a membership and I
understand the frustration with patreon
but if your idea was to support the
David Pakman show I would hope that you
also don't punish us by virtue of being
mad at patreon so some of you I'd say
maybe about 15% of the people who have
canceled their pledges have come over to
david pakman.com slash membership and
created a membership only about 15% and
most have not so please please PLEASE
switch over to membership if you are
canceling your patreon pledge I believe
patreon is ultimately going to fix this
and it will sort of become water under
the bridge but in the meantime if you
are looking at switching you can go to
david pakman.com slash membership you
can pick a monthly membership a yearly
membership whatever works and there is a
coupon code if you want to get a bit of
a discount which is I voted 17 and on
that note I finally have here a physical
copy of the 2018 David Pakman show
calendar and it is absolutely fantastic
and when you look in it you will see
100% original viewer submitted art
you've got a cartoon I'm pointing to a
drawing of Donald Trump
and you've got Sarah Huckabee Sanders a
bearded David Pakman makes an appearance
Al Franken makes an appearance George W
Bush it's a fantastic calendar and you
can get one of these for free at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 you can get
a calendar at no cost and autographed if
you sign up for a new David Pakman show
membership at david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 option 2 there when you go
to david pakman.com slash calendar 18 is
the ability to purchase just the
calendar if you're currently a member or
a patron or you're not and you only want
the calendar you can use option 2 there
click here under option 2 and you can
get just the calendar autographed or not
so we're sending these out now to people
all over the world very exciting check
it out the goal is 250 calendars for
this season we're up to 70 already so we
are we are working our way there